every Tuesday like today's Tuesday our
eye on money series looks at financial
issues affecting Americans this morning
we're focusing on the high cost of
fertility treatments about 13 and 100
American couples have trouble getting
pregnant infertility treatments like IVF
cost more than $10,000 a cycle freezing
your eggs on average is between thirty
and forty thousand dollars cheaper
options like intrauterine insemination
may cost three hundred to one thousand
dollars a lot of money refinery29
released an anonymous infertility diary
chronicling one woman's difficult
journey after an initial consultation
nearly two years ago she had three
rounds of intrauterine insemination and
is in the middle of her first round of
IVF get this she has already spent
twenty six thousand six hundred dollars
refinery29 senior vice president Julie
Alvin is with us Julie good morning good
morning
the dollar signs next to these
treatments I mean just jaw-dropping yes
and on top of those sticker prices there
are even more underneath that there are
hidden cost what are those so there are
various consultations there are
medication costs so a lot of times when
you're talking about the cost of a
particular procedure that's not taking
into account all the medications that
you have to pay for to prepare yourself
for that procedure if you're doing egg
freezing there's also eggs storage which
can cost up to a thousand dollars a year
there's various consultations if you
have the means to talk to different
fertility specialists those may or may
not be covered by your insurance only
excuse me sixty percent of people have
to pay out-of-pocket for all of these
cost because they have no fertility
coverage no interesting talk about means
and in this context because what people
have is desire and meaning to start a
family pay almost anything you'll find a
way does insurance cover some of it all
of it
it depends definitely on the company and
on the insurance policy so like I said
sixty percent of people have to pay
entirely out of pocket for fertility
treatments
some places will cover a little bit so
you know they might cover clomid which
is a shot that helps stimulate ovulation
or they might cover a portion of the
medications for egg freezing or IVF but
it's pretty rare that a place will cover
all of the treatments
and you know most people are stuck
trying to put this bill and it really is
a socio-economic issue as well because
it's people who are you know in
positions of privilege who are able to
do this and people who is there is there
any way to get financial help other than
your insurance or something like this so
there are certain ways there are ways to
sort of bring down costs in general so
you know certainly talk to your
insurance and figure out what your
different options are
we also would recommend talking to so we
did this big package called fertility
spectrum on refinery29 that's all about
kind of educating the different path
towards pregnancy the different costs
and opening that dialogue and we partner
with an organization called fertility IQ
that is a great resource for all this
information on cost different procedures
doctors so going there and making sure
that you know you're aware of the
different costs involved we also worked
with a place called extend fertility I
personally worked with them and they
offer egg freezing at 40% below the
national average what do you have
national average the national average I
believe is and so the number you quoted
is probably for several treatments so
11,000 is the national average for the
actual retrieval procedure but then
there's also around if you don't have
any insurance coverage around $5,000 a
medication cost in addition to $1,000 a
year so I would recommend going to
clinics like that who you know we had an
excellent experience with them do it for
less and there are also grants and
scholarships actually for tuning when do
you know Julie that you need to go down
this road and what questions should you
be asked so typically you are given a
diagnosis of infertility which is sort
of a negative term we're trying to move
away from everyone or a 20-9 after a
year of trying to conceive just through
you know your method yeah and after that
it's typically time to seek fertility
treatment but I would definitely
recommend trying to educate yourself on
the process beforehand and figuring out
sort of where you might sit on the
fertility spectrum we have a
questionnaire online that's kind of
although all the questions you should
ask your doctor right right Julie thank
you for coming yeah Julie Alvin thank
you very much for being here thanks so
much